make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
ah fYI patrons those of you guys who are
patrons make sure you check out the
announcement announcement posts that I
made on patreon about the start of our
next uncensored uncensored video series
I think you guys are really gonna like
it so it's the next uncensored series
it's gonna be on patreon only no holds
barred you'll probably hear me cussing
they're definitely like swear words and
all kinds of stuff in the comic uh yeah
so like comics explained uncut basically
that's all you guys are gonna see it but
uh but any event we're finally getting
back into spawn Armageddon right and a
lot of you guys really seemed to enjoy
it which I'm really happy to see right
because I wasn't sure if you guys were
really going to enjoy this series or not
but I'm glad you guys are glad you guys
loved it but we're kind of reaching the
finality right like we've got this video
and I think we've got one more and then
we're done with spawn Armageddon and
then we go into the aftermath cuz I
guess we're gonna keep spawn going but
in any event if you guys want to get
caught up I have a playlist for spawn
now right has like the origins video the
origin of his character the introduction
of Angela and then it goes directly into
what we've covered so far so you can get
caught up quick fast and in a hurry with
regards to the to the mythos not a whole
lot of videos I think it's maybe like
three or four videos up to this point
but in any event we're kind of picking
up here with with really the aftermath
of Wanda had basically you know offed
herself because everything she's learned
here has really just been too much to
process right this idea that her twin
children aren't really her twin children
instead they're basically God and Satan
reborn in human form now again this
really ties into the mother of all
creation which is to say the creator of
the universe this being that created all
these various gods across the entirety
of the universe offer every civilization
that exists out there and of all the
gods who were created God and Satan are
deemed to be failures because instead of
serving the role which was assigned to
them which is to say the traditional
judeo-christian role instead they
basically just bicker amongst each other
and so in order to teach them what it
meant to be human the mother of all
creation essentially sealed them away
and then recreated their essences in
human form right and that's where we
kind of are right now but the toll of
Wanda learning that basically her
children her twin children are God and
Satan is far more than she can grasp and
so because of all that with it being too
much to handle and all this kind of
really you know coming coming to a head
Wanda ends up going into the bedroom you
know as we saw and then grabbing the gun
and turning it on herself now where we
ended the last video with per the
presumption that Wanda had died instead
the mother of all creation froze time
and the reason why is because
what this meant is it basically allowed
the mother of all creation to address
spawn and is simply say I understand how
important she is to you
right because without her you would lose
your will to fight and it's important
that you fight and so what this does is
it allows spawn to basically pull the
bullet away and then to keep Wanda alive
and so again this is kind of yet another
instance on the stack of all these
things that have made life ridiculously
difficult for her and so in response to
that of course you have Terry who's
basically freaking out the response to
spawn is do something right do something
to fix this and to make it right and so
as a result of that what the mother of
creation does is she basically wipes
Wanda's mind of everything now it's also
told that she wipes the mind of Terry
and cyan but what we're gonna learn
about cyan is that's not necessarily the
case right Terry's kind of made to
forget about the twins the fact that
they were God and Satan and all that
kind of stuff and and Wanda was as well
presumably so as I am but at this moment
it's really more of the role that cyan
is gonna play and the reason why is
because what the mother of creation does
is she basically leaves with spawn and
what she tells him is that this role
you're going to play in Armageddon this
final battle between God and Satan is a
war that you need to be prepared for and
at the moment you are not cyan it's
going to be the person that's going to
save you why she's going to be the one
this is basically going to put you in a
position to where you can win this war
and that's why we saw in the previous
video when the mother of all creation
was more or less musing you know was the
man of miracles the mother of all
creation was saying a child will save
everyone and that's exactly what this is
it's cyan basically being the person
who's going to guide the Swan to success
and the reason why this matters is
because spawn has to face off against
the disciple but in order to kind of
create this bridge with cyan what he has
to do is show her his true face to show
her what spawn really is and so
ultimately he ends up visiting her and
then basically kind of opens himself up
and pours out this massive collection of
insects essentially saying like I am a
monster right I'm a monster of the worst
kind how you've seen me is not how I
truly am you have to see me at my
absolute worst and that's when you know
he's these kind of you know it's kind of
guess only bugs it's only bugs it's only
bugs and the result is that she
basically screams out you're not a
monster and what this does is it
solidifies the bond between cyan and Al
Simmons she genuinely and truly accepts
him as he is and that's what was needed
it's game theory his success depends on
the success of cyan and truly accepting
him for who
yes and so because of that it's one of
these things were essentially the
enraptured has begun to start right
which is to say people being brought up
to heaven and to serve God more or less
and it's kind of a funny thing because
what we get is this this kind of
monologue of sorts you know where we're
sian talked about what the rapture is
right at least in terms of what her
grandma had told her the rapture wasn't
was about now what I want to do here is
I want to sidetrack for a second and I
want to have this conversation about
granny Blake right because this is one
of those themes that was kind of covered
over the course of a lot of the spawn
comics leading up to this point now
granny Blake is not the most significant
character and the entire spawn mythos
but she also kind of is and the reason
why is because she really served in a
lot of ways as a kind of religious
advisor for spawn nothing so far is
saying like here's what you need to do
in order to win the favor of God and
Satan but whenever spawn felt like he
was kind of drifting off the path or he
was trying to reconcile his existence
with the existence of like God and Satan
and that kind of a thing trying to
figure out his place in all of this
granny was the one that kind of guided
him back they basically said God and
Satan they're beings and really kind of
a spouse the judeo-christian belief
system of God and Satan so on and so
forth because of that she was a
character that like a lot of fans got
attached to because of kind of like the
emotional support that that she offered
now eventually they kind of went their
own way but it was one of these things
where granny Blake was blind right so
there was this kind of sort of
supernatural essence about her in the in
the sense that she could see things that
other people couldn't normally see and
that's what created the sort of rapport
between herself and spawn now eventually
they kind of had a falling-out they
really stopped communicating different
things like that but this is why granny
is really kind of receiving a lot of
emphasis here right because in the eyes
of granny she looked at the idea of
Heaven and Hell and looked at it in the
traditional judeo-christian place she's
going to a place where God truly loves
her and different things along those
lines
she'll be reunited with her husband and
that's how she sees it here right you
know as she's making her way from Earth
her spiritual essence or I guess her
physical form is leaving earth you know
it's part of the rapture and then
entering into heaven she's reunited with
Jack her former husband who died she
basically kind of takes on this
appearance of her being her younger
beautiful self and of course she's she's
kind of there looking at like God and
and so on and so forth now this is all
really given to us it's kind of like the
the monologue of Sian right in terms of
this is what granny always told me God
you know heaven was going to be like
right and so it's kind of like your
granny's perception of what heaven
should be the reality is anything but
right as soon as she gets there and she
passes through the
early gates there's no Jack there right
there's no you know heavenly choir of
angels singing you know and welcome to
heaven
you know there's none of that stuff
right nobody from her past life that she
knew who's they're waiting on or
anything like that there's simply just
God as the child and with granny being
unable to see what's really going on God
basically says then let me return your
sight to you he gives her her eyesight
back in which he sees what's up what she
sees is this enormous army that's being
formed right the Seraphim of God
Zehra basically leading them all these
various soldiers who are there and all
these humans who are there who have no
clue what's going on right because
heaven as it exists is not what they've
been led to believe and that's kind of
the the crushing sensation of it all is
nothing is what they thought it would be
and that's what that's really what
granny says you know this is not what
heaven is supposed to be heaven is
supposed to be like God loves us and
it's supposed to be the pearly gates and
it's supposed to be happiness
everlasting and in what what is this
twisted in screwed up place and that's
when God kind of chimes in of like okay
so like there's what you've been told
and then there's what it really is right
like I'm not I'm like the like the
vengeful guy right like I'm the guy
great vengeance am i tearing things up
and punishing the wicked that's my kind
of thing right and so as a result of
this gods like you all have been brought
here because I need an army because like
we're gonna go to war with hell and I
kind of need an army so like you've been
conscripted and basically Rhema T
realises all these humans here into his
heavenly soldiers and so following that
what you end up doing is you end up
jumping to spawn picking up with with
the mother of creation and essentially
going to face off against the disciple
now one thing to understand this is not
the first time it's fawn and the
disciple have met each other and in fact
they met each other during spawn issue
number 50 where the disciple took out
spawn quick fast and in a hurry the big
indication there is that the reason why
spawn lost is because one he didn't
really have the ability to tap into the
six thousand souls who were part of his
body but also because it was him just
fighting on his own
whereas here he also has the belief of
sian kind of backing him right somebody
who has faith in him now the reason why
this is taking place is because when
this battle concludes if spawn passes
this test then spawn will prove himself
worthy of the power of the mother of
creation right not insofar as he will
become the mother of creation but
insofar as spawn will become a God which
is to say divine spawn as a lot of you
guys probably know him my spawn with the
angel or with the wings and all that
kind of stuff so with that being the
case and cyan kind of back
when he goes to face off against the
against the disciple it's it's kind of a
tough battle at first but after that
after a while
spawn starts to get the upper hand on
the disciple now one thing I want you to
notice here is that on this guy's head
he basically has the Roman numeral 4:12
and there's a reason for that
right spawn gets the upper hand on this
guy takes him out pretty pretty quickly
and then kind of comments it should not
be this easy right and that's what he
was warned about the mother the mother
of creation said much like you the
disciple is more than what he seems so
be aware of that when this version of
disciple is is defeated then suddenly
the disciple 11 pops up and what what
disciple 11 says is the person you
thought before was James the less right
he was the weakest of all of us now
you're fighting me I'm Simon Peter the
rock and so what this does is it allows
you know with the help of of Sian who's
really kind of engaging in this battle
all mostly kind of a video game
situation it allows some of the the
souls of spawn to emerge and basically
face-off against these other other
disciples while spawn really seems to
kind of go for the main prize now the
other part of this is that what you have
is the return of the timer that
countdown timer now this is old hat in a
lot of ways the timer was originally
part of the spawn mythos when it first
came up right in the idea but spawn only
had a finite amount of energy and when
that energy ran down to zero that
basically spawned would more or less die
now in this instance the timer is much
lower than it was before and so if you
guys are familiar with video games this
is in effect a boss battle is basically
what this is right and it's cool is it's
a really really cool depiction of this
whole thing but spawn facing off against
these various disciples and ultimately
overcoming them all and almost kind of
like a montage fashion right like
overcoming each one of these guys
basically leads him to facing off
against the final disciple this is Judas
Iscariot now Judas Iscariot in
judeo-christianity was the guy who sold
out Jesus for thirty pieces of silver
what we're gonna find out here is that
in terms of the spawn mythos there was a
lot more to it than that but spawn
fighting against Judas Iscariot proves
to be exceedingly difficult right he is
wildly powerful and so it's interesting
because what spawn was told is that in
the beginning you have to put your trust
in cyan cyan knows what she's doing
trust her no matter what she tells you
believe in what she tells you and so as
his power begins to sort of dwindle down
as his power begins to die off that
eventually cyan comes to the realization
that he has to sacrifice himself where
Swan goes in for the kill the response
to cyan is
No you have to stop do not kill him let
him kill you instead let him destroy you
and initially spawns reaction is no
that's kind of ridiculous that isn't
making any sense right like I have to
pass the test I have to prove how
powerful I am by taking out these
various disciples and the response of
Sian is no no no don't do that basically
let this guy win at the same time that
all that's happening the Armageddon is
officially beginning right you know the
the whole end of times is officially
starting as it does at least according
to the book of the book of rapture which
is with the massive earthquake that
basically shakes the world right and
begins the process of like the coming of
the Four Horsemen and the bowls of God's
wrath and the sounding of the trumpets
and all that kind of stuff it begins
here and so the result is that taking
this moment doing exactly what it is it
is supposed to do the disciple
essentially impale spawn and kill spawn
if that's correct which it is what this
means is that spawn has officially
passed the test and what this means is
that going forward spawn will achieve
the power of all creation right spawn is
now elevated to the power of a god
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are no
year to comments explain and make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the rod core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace I want
to say thank you to all of the new
patrons who have joined patreon.com
slash comics explained I want to give a
shout out to Henry young - Elias G David
J s Jacob H Ben John H Jason see Austin
s Austin H James O kristymatt in Jeff
are Joey M Steven Z sloth-like Lou David
see John H lean and mean that guy asked
questions all the time Adam Cajun gnosis
916 I want to say thank you to all of
you all this list is growing all the
time thank you joining the patreon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]